and and really if we want to move to
other planets outside our solar system
i think realistically that's a much
better
option than thinking that humans will
actually make these gigantic journeys
and
you know then i do this calculation for
my class you know
einstein's special theory of relativity
says that you can do it in a short
amount of time
in your own frame of reference if you go
close to the speed of light
but then you bring in e equals m c
squared and you figure out how much
energy it takes to get you accelerated
to
close enough to the speed of light to
make the time scale
short in your own frame of reference and
the amount of energy is just
unfathomable right we can do it at the
large hadron collider
with with protons you know we can
accelerate them to 99.999 percent of the
speed of light
but that's just a proton we're
gazillions of protons okay
and that doesn't even count the rocket
that would carry us the payload
and you would need to either store the
fuel in the rocket which
then requires even more mass for the
rocket or collect
fuel along the way which you know is
difficult and
so getting close to the speed of light i
think is not an option either
other than for a little tiny thing like
you know yuri milner and others are
thinking about this
this star shot project where they'll
send a little tiny camera
to alpha centauri 4.2 light years away
they'll zip past it
take a picture of the exoplanets that we
know orbit
that three or more star system and uh
say hello real say hello real quickly
and then send the images back to us okay
yeah so that that's a tiny little thing
right maybe you can accelerate that to
they're hoping 20 of the speed of light
with a whole bunch of high-powered
lasers
aimed at it it's not clear that other
countries will allow us to do that by
the way
yeah but that's a very forward-looking
thought i mean i very much support
the idea but there's a big difference
between sending a little tiny camera
and sending a payload of people with
equipment
that could then mine the
um the resources on the exoplanet that
they reach
and and then go forth and multiply right
you